I would get frustrated with J for
wanting me to come I was like why can't
you just me and come and like why
do you have to worry about these ladies
where's my lunch ladies don't worry
about I'm sorry I just yeah I you have
to come first there's not gonna happen I
guess I'm a piece of like that
happiest kids in the world to me by you
know per capita seems to be these rich
kids who end up in my building who their
parents pay for them where they go to
college to just party yeah in my
building we'll see what's now this party
it is my building the apartments are
expensive
but there's five of them living in an
apartment and they just up and
they seem super happy the girls seem
dark yeah but see like for me it was the
drinking was a little more sad because I
didn't have any money coming in from
family so you're just like dead bro no
you're getting broke you know like when
you're getting up because it's
like sure it's fun but also it makes
sleeping on an air mattress and
windowless room better I didn't hit too
dark until my early 30s when you're like
I think I'm a dark dark weird
failure yes I think I'm failing it that
funny the 30s is the hangover the 20s
we're just like oh oh great idea
that's profound
it really is cuz I look back on my 20s
I'm like it was blissful I was broke and
it's like not healthy and hungover all
the time but I had the best time I've
had the best time getting up I
really like if you're getting up
currently and still drinking I always
like to say just have some fun because
you're gonna get to a place where you
can't do it anymore
and I look back and I'm like I had the
best time and I won't ever go back to it
and it's a very brief time of like enjoy
drinking heaviest of a guy yeah it was
like three years ago it was should've
been in my teens or have a great time no
Christine was drinking too and she's not
that great
so haywire but that was my but that was
my only time doesn't drink now at all
but like that was my only time really
drinking I didn't do much my daughter
you oh yeah yeah yeah man I really lived
hand-to-mouth for a while it's fun up
until you quit when it stops being not
fun anymore
it gets awful who have guilt over
drinking around me sometimes it'll be
like I wasn't weird but they're still
having fun with drinking it hasn't
become a sad thing I'm always like no I
watch Bert Kreischer and I'm like I wish
I could drink again that uh like I want
to drink with Bert people that I was a
real heavy heavy documentary about the
guitar player from corn dog I left and
came back yeah
but uh he talks about in that
documentary the lead singer from corn
said he was one of the first ones to get
sober yeah and he said when he got sober
they were like worried about like
partying around him stilling everything
he said he was like no I loved he goes I
just he was I still really enjoy the act
of like cut it in the lines and
everything for everybody I was like
still prep it for every because I just
can't do it but yeah it's not causing
your lives to fall apart go for it and
as soon as those people click people get
worried about getting sober that you're
you're gonna lose all your friends but
what happens is you just like see what
you thought you were having fun doing
and then you kind of see it clearly and
you're like oh this isn't this fun and
then you just naturally don't want to do
it it's not like you're like I long to
have fun like that again yeah I walked
by this bar and I was used to
romanticize it for my drinking like my
hard drinking days and I'm like it's
just such a great neighborhood scummy
bloody me walk by now and you're like oh
now you get your joy watching grown men
in costumes fake fight like that that's
healthy that has no psychological
reprimands at all dampen your Lance
wrestling yeah dude I don't know my life
drinking was a lot of fun but he was
also very destructive at the same time I
was I was just like you know you were
physically destroying physically
destroying me what if you would have
been drunk at that event that you're
talking about being joyful at that has
an a bunch of acronyms I don't care to
remember the WWE another WWE Monday
Night Raw okay yeah I was at Raw last
night if I would've gotten drunk last
night that would have been the best for
the first hour and then I would have
been obnoxious again what I just always
argue about the drinking things I just
don't fully understand is the the day
after the next if it's the same thing
the same mistake yeah
day after day that Christine's explained
it to me as as best she can and I don't
think it's a bad explanation although I
just don't get it when I was like if you
know for drinks is where you get like
it's a fun night we're having a really
fun night dead by the time you're at
three and a half and you see four
closing in right you're like I'm gonna
get five six and seven but here's my
thing I'm what I don't understand is but
you know for sure as last night and the
two before told you five and six are the
ones where you puke but you're right
here and still you believe goes no but
tonight she's saying the basically
you're saying that no but tonight is
just gonna maintain that buzz because
the person in your head that's supposed
to stop you at four gets drunk exactly
it straight up you're inside brain is
hammered it's like go smoke a cigarette
come back yeah dude that's my favorite
that was my favorite drunk thought of
all time it always be like dude who's
telling you not to do that you should do
it well most of my step up and
do it
most of my drunks have been with you
cristy most of my drunks been with you
have I made do you think though I would
say my mind like my brain function of of
what should happen next
does stay sober when you agree with it's
a bizarre thing and like I never I never
lose like I would never have a thing
like I said I've never I can't wrap my
brain around the idea if somebody came
up to me and was like sir I'm gonna have
to ask you to leave I would immediately
assume I am the one who did something
wrong and I would be like I'm sorry did
I up am I drunk and I that's
how I would react even if I'm slurring
words I go I would assume it was me I
would never be in a place going to
that off the go anyway let me
say you were drunk dan would be
I can win them back
[Laughter]
why are we doing this what's up okay
who's telling me not to yeah I'm gonna
do it because she's telling me not you
know what I wake up the same as I went
to sleep breathing and walking here we
go here then I wake up to go work a dose
and I'd be like I think I'm gonna throw
up and everything is sideways I put my
pants on like everybody else pants I go
to sleep and that's where I dream where
I dream is when I plan and when I plan
to execute life is short
that's always my shirt is such that take
another shot it's just carpe diem FOMO
like all of that just like why are you
just just and that's what I do with
everything in life though anything I
want to convince myself to do I just go
everyone who could maybe judge me for
this is gonna die and then the people
that they tell are gonna die like you
know easy would be for me to become 500
pounds of my life if I live I gotta ha
whose why would I not have I didn't
think about mission accomplished we were
talking earlier about the not on the
show before the show about the things
that a guy will dial back to if it's not
gonna happen sexually I said I when you
get to that point where later
immediately after you come you go like
that was ridiculous that I even asked
for that thing to happen but I'm so for
a good example if I remember a time I
said I was hooking up with a girl and I
made her come quick I think eating her
and then I thought it was taunting
them but then she had like one of those
like we shouldn't be doing this or
whatever it was but she was like
whatever why she didn't want to do this
thing and theirs was he when you dial
back and you're like we just do the
interest like I guess you know you could
jerk off if you want and then you'll be
doing that
she's not making the negotiating can you
kind of see a titty can you grab the
base or something take the things if I
brought against your calf is that cool
is one like two or three little I
wouldn't have not the feet a little bit
but if a girl goes the only thing that's
gonna happen you have a rager
and I've already come you can my
toes I think about those toes
yeah if she was like you can TSA Wan me
with your body's not moving today boss
coming right away with a guy I just
don't relate to that in a hook-up and
then I also don't relate to me like I
have this sense of obligation to make a
guy come that I would i don't relate at
all to being like i mean i definitely
have been that's great i love the good
devotion it's like don't you understand
and even if you were like can I jerk off
I'd be like yeah that's all I don't have
to do anything useless shirk off on me
great like that is that's just but
you've never been approached that
because you wouldn't make a guy just
jerk off and first I mean there have
been times where I've hooked up with a
guy recently where I'm like you have not
earned me to touch your dick in any way
you've done nothing to me and they and
they want to come and I know that
they're not gonna be able to make me
come and so we're kind of just had a
stalemate where they're like why do you
know that you can't with a new bring me
and it's worthless coaching that is
gonna it's just they're not saying the
right things
I'm already just it's what's the most
coaching with a fingering you'll hang in
there for I've made a joke onstage so
much about a guy fingering over him most
girls say lots of guys think they go in
overhand finger no wife very bizarre
uppercuts
I think problem is you hit that shallow
you hit the shallow uppercuts problem is
if
might be jerking off to a tip that's a
good point
have you ever do too well he has a man
ever made you came and then you're like
well we're hit we're good here no no but
I will say I've been in that predicament
of like I don't want to touch your dick
I'm not gonna blow you because you
haven't earned it you're just you're not
but I do want you to come because I want
you to have a good experience and your
dick is hard and I don't want to leave
you feeling unsatisfied and I want to
have like a fun weird sexual experience
so I'll be like just jerk off I'll watch
or whatever or man is that hot I think
guys are weird about it now because of
all the Blooey stuff like oh I don't
want to jerk off in front of a girl
that's weird I'm like no it's awesome do
you think before that they were like are
you in common you got drunk enough extra
not unwanted but if I asked you to
that's it's hot it could be so hot and
so this guy in particular so we were
like we're making out and stuff I knew
that he was not even gonna do anything
to me that how did you really come
because he wasn't saying the right
things he wasn't
Jacob sneaking no speaking keywords
search on this version later his
shoulders back the posture of a
gentleman I like that Nikki cases it
like cases dudes like you know like she
knows like pickpockets you know she goes
I could tell by the way he walked you
wrong she was walking in I knew I was
dry I was gonna be dry for the whole
night bring back my old timey music glue
talking like this again like me enough
to give a you know like he just
wanted to come that was what this was
about you thought that was new yeah and
I just didn't I used to fear obligation
to have them come I didn't want them in
this particular instance I didn't care
if he came or not but I was gonna get
something a story out of it or at least
like just something weird sexually
because I like to be a little bit
deviant sometimes and throw mice and I'm
sober and so it's hard for me to be as
deviant as they used to be yeah and so
it was like I was in like a leotard it's
a long story but I original dance moves
did you give any details please go for
dessert
trailer and like daytime hooking up was
I wasn't it wasn't late
maybe I wasn't gonna come because I was
like you're not comfortable because a PA
could have walked in or what do you mean
it was knock on a trailer is a real
boner killer and he was just like can
you do what do you and and I don't even
know that he wanted me to do anything
but I decided I didn't even want to jerk
him off through his pants like he didn't
deserve my hand I felt I don't know why
and also I just don't feel that
confident and handjobs I think I also
avoid them because I'm just like good
for your steen what's your car better to
be yeah you're good because a bad one
will make you I just
bumble around with it fumble the ball
right when you get it took my I was
straddling him and I just like went like
this with my shin like I just kind of
like oh my god you did the cat move I
was joking about I'm not joking whoo I
did that and he didn't come but it was
kind of hot and funny skin-on-skin it
wasn't even his skin it was through his
boxers but I just did that for a while
we were talking um bros oh we're saying
those that's those are the shorts are
those that's the if a girl
me that's a great handjob or out that's
a great fabric for that well it's the
perfect one and all the Italian man
jumpsuits yes
suede suede is wade ah damn dick skin on
Wade suede suede soft for women it's
like the best thing to get fingered
through Christine like shorts best thing
your finger through Christine is going
to answer her like soaked through
because you're gonna get wet so you
wanted to be a little bit like a coarser
material like a corduroy alright I don't
know if I've ever just done over the
past while you girls are syncing up
periods dan thinks it would be okay to
get jacked off with suede and he's
arguing that it's a soft material that
would feel good
they will not it will rip your dick off
dams like check over the baseball mitt
you psycho changes color would you like
rub your whole Colorado we call that a
little Fort Collins handy because I'm
gonna go jerk off past my naugahyde Dan
wrap it around your dick dude oh
yeah give yourself a good Pete won't you
stick your dick between those two suede
flaps on the way I'm gonna rip your pee
hole open
is there anything to this my friend the
guy who comes out on the road with me
he's on my show all the time Andrew :
he um he thinks he needs he's jerked off
with his hand for so long cuz he's been
single that in DRI he doesn't like use
Lube so like now he's having sex in
seven he's like it's all too wet like I
can't what I need more I need drier -
this is Chris first first off does that
make any sense because Godric I dry jerk
yes okay Wow we're onto something this
is opening up a whole new thing that's
that's real use lotion or Lube to pull
out Lube to jerk off is downright
ridiculous it's like a brand of Lube
like a little warming Joey I got a to
move it at CVS on the road I was like
I'm a bee to this why not dude I found
it at the CVS you absolutely should if
it's a good hotel jerk it's like a treat
you bring it on the road with you on
your bag like it's Purell hit the can
looks like our flights delayed about a
half-hour
[Music]
he's jerk dragon grab my door can I pull
on it at all of cours what will happen
when you're jerking off there's gonna be
a little sad like you know the garbage
Indian tear and I will I will take the
thumb across that and I'll work that
right around you know the rim of the
is your like a person that has a
freshwater well like that's I said after
I'm a pretty sexual person and I'll go
for it I've had someone was defending me
online but on the SDR show one time I
said after that what do you when you
come what do you like put in the tissues
and yeah till that stuff and I go no
generally when I jerk off is in a hotel
before I'm gonna take a shower okay or
at home like you know somewhere between
10 minutes to an hour before I take a
shower and I go now generally it's like
first of all it's not I'm not blowing
like porn loads I'm sure I go
I'll just kinda like go like I said I
put on my goddamn thigh and get ready
for the shower whenever the
Kristine's definitely walk to a store
next to me with all over her body in
some way that's going to my spank that
verb adjectives teaching a summer
school to Korean students cuz Korean
parents don't send let their kids meet
bukkake do they love that over in Korea
my son tells me that I had to meet the
teacher who smells like it's a little
brie cheese
how'd you find that out when you got
home I just I don't know if I actually
had come on me but I was in
circumstances where I did not shower
after having a night of filthy sex and I
would go into work it was one time on a
lunch break where I gave a guy a handjob
and I remember going back to work being
like I am like I felt I had a skip in my
step because I'm like what us what you
Mon there little flat faces with your
cup with your phone with your salty dick
hand oh dude that was a waitress at the
cellar one time that's me as like joking
but dead serious
and she goes uh how I want to sell tell
your name off everyone knows or she she
comes over like laughingly and she puts
her hand over my like face and nose and
I was like what it and she goes she goes
I just jerked a guy off and then I could
when she said it's it's spit and
dicks all gym guys will work out next to
me on the treadmill once they start
sweating like whatever calm is on them
shorts like it's not just coming it's
like spitty dick didn't she just walk up
and put her hand on your face and say
smell like dick and start laughing no
she says she was ejected she was I just
jerked off a guy oh I couldn't be that
man it was so funny she's not lying
it smells like she definitely jerked off
a dude's hands when I've just washed my
hands in their wet I won't guy just but
every guy every guy here for sure has
gone to a store also conversely with Wow
I don't know everybody here might be
naked but I've definitely had
girl juice dude and when you get to the
store you start seeing it just turns
white later like you're alright like
you're trying on ketamine it's like
that's so fun it's like toothpaste on
the corner of your mouth what dude I had
almost having a beard like this also you
will definitely like it we're just
getting to it's going to a store and
being like just like it's just it's
soaking wet is with it yeah Wow dude I
had a funny one where I that when I work
to care for me should I care from a day
and two sometimes this it's a real thing
it's not even real thing at all this
girl came to the radio station and I
titty her in an office and then
there a Jani Lane warrant post it's
really awesome
stank poster oh yeah and I came and we
cleaned it up or whatever and I was
wearing these like thin khaki shorts and
I went and my post come had just leaks
on me so you could just see like a
puddle of come like we're murdered by
like soft dick was or whatever and I
just walked into I was having a
conversation with all these people in
like the cafeteria area and then
I left in the girl I was with she's like
actually this might happen to girls on a
as might happen to women on a much
larger level because one of the worst
things to when you and as soon as
you finish put your underwear
back on as a guy yeah sometimes later
you don't realize that you're like dick
hole has kind of become like glued to
the floor year a quick moment when it
pulls off it's like getting your eyebrow
is that something on a girl level it
must submit does ever get like where
it's almost or just kind of like just
wet not stick to it no we say we keep a
damp down there so give us a chance to
really you don't paper mache at all no
it doesn't dry and then hook in yeah to
what yeah yeah if you're under where you
get to what you're just like throw in
your bag yeah don't hit your bag we get
rid of them you slob what do you keep
yeah I think yes you get like turned on
giver get true do you ever really talk
to a guy and you don't even realize you
like him till you go to the bathroom
later and you're like what that was
slick whoa what happened up there and
then I go oh yeah that one thing turned
me on for a second that's so funny we
don't get delayed boners one-mississippi
we all learn that from poltergeist oh is
that where that got started that's where
I heard first count the seconds between
you know it's getting further or close
my mother taught me that just like well
your mother learned it from poltergeist
and she tried to pass a level she was a
philosopher she was smoking her cob pipe
she told me she told me that astrology
is next knowing the gold Jan I'm gonna
give you the only wisdom I have to count
between lightning and thunder and you'll
not go thermoses for thermoses use
either screwdrivers and lightning you
can count Steve to go to break yeah
we're taking our last break though and
then we get to come back and go to the
whole way well my dad just recently
called me but can I just tell this
question about parent parental advice
apparently a Thursday we play by our own
rules here then they change the system
we have to take hardline commercial as
Jacob says he's terrified okay okay when
I sense that it's urgent I'll speed it
up okay at all
NPR this um you know the girl that
just recently got into the wrong over
and then was yeah yeah down in Carolina
terrible yeah disclaimer that it goes
I'm against that I do want to say it's
the most unlucky day of her life and the
luckiest day of that murderers life
that's it that a girl just he he happens
to be a murderer I don't think he sought
her out I think he was just driving
through town a girl got his carne goes
oh I guess
from his perspective he really was like
I mean fate really brought us together I
mean that's the thing you can argue fate
for all these things that you are
positive in your life like that's the
reason but a guy could justify murdering
someone if he's like you know gods show
me a sign that I should not murder like
if I shouldn't murder don't give me a
sign but if I meant to in his crazy
brain boom there's a sign what yeah
anyway my dad calls me the next day and
is like you heard about this girl you
know that I told your mom that would
never happen to you I'm like okay first
of all she was drunk okay oh yeah yeah
yeah
but you know better you know that my
dad's only advice to me in self-defense
against men is if a man gets you in a
car and it is good advice you gouge his
eyes out just stick your two fingers as
deep as you can into his eyes because
even if he crashes the car you have a
better chance of surviving the crash
than you do wherever he's taking you and
it is like that's statistically accurate
that's a smart piece of advice it is the
old glaze a gouge guy whose eyes that
you gouged out he was taking you to this
like beautiful place he built for you I
bet in love with you and I've been
writing you letters and I thought you
corresponded I am everything you go was
he handsome you got one think about it
when he had eyes he was pretty handsome
that was the best thing about him god
damn it I could smell the warm come on
he showing you the seven lay the seven
story tree house he built you your dream
your dream enchanted dream house love
the way he used to look at this is made
with no animal products good for the
tree look you have your little joke
reading nook I would show you but my
eyes are guys cuz your father is a
boxcar boy I'm gonna put my hand your
shoulder can you can you walk me and
assist me in the bathroom you tell me
what I'm done wiping Nicky I'm sorry I
know I used to be very attractive to you
but now you tell me is your poop on this
paper
this advice your dad gave her over a can
of beans by a campfire in a junkyard he
goes now you ever loan with a man in a
car yeah I just he's probably from the
government sorry
are you done with your pot of beans like
when do you go for the gouge though
there's the thing like when do you go so
many steps ahead I'm like how does this
guy ever find out when he's done wiping
with he hasn't had a woman who loves
yeah that's a good point
you've embarrassed him the rest of his
life but gouged his eyes out even when
he's in sitting if he goes to prison for
what he's done why I'm against violence
against men who are violent against
women yes and why would you be hurting a
man that would is doing this out of love
so you've definitely heard the
WorldStarHipHop rants of like a girl
taking the thing to be like if he don't
beat you is because he don't care and
they meet there are so good it's like
someone's telling you flat earth with
like a straight face they go
no there's nothing kidding here he goes
if he hasn't hit you it's because he has
no passion for you that's always great I
did not make Christine believe it broken
women like this just calls it abuse
every time I'm like no what do you know
I'm hitting you some passionate about
we're doing this food is cold I'm very
passionate of people one day you won't
know the timing of the dishes I just
know that if I ever get murdered my dad
is gonna be like she just didn't like
that's gonna be the story more while
they're walking him to the court in the
courtroom your dad's gonna stand up ago
did she go for your eyes she did like or
be funny well in the car accident in the
car accident
Nicky died but that guy survived when he
went to court I think he's dead went to
court showed him the guy walked in with
the glasses and he takes them off and
he has Jerry Orbach size through don't
go can't do it's not a chance Bolan did
one yesterday at the stand that was the
she's all about it he said yeah well
guess some things are better than
everybody it's like the rats and fleed
the ship yes sir it's what you think in
a dress ooh it's Murphy from TVs billion
they're staring us we have to do a fake
kiss now
not everybody's watching but the entire
desk at everyone who's watching which is
the best part I look over my shoulder
every tardes was like the first time I
life I have no idea what to do when we
walk in that door tomorrow forgets never
happened I didn't think that if an
entire glass window of everybody that's
why I took the holy we blur things
you guys film the people inside looking
everyone was looking I went over your
shoulder to take a peek also I think I
lost this guy's is that kind of guy I
want them no billions in the
queer yo think everyone's looking
at is I don't know what to do there I
want to go her to different entrance we
go on from the frescoes I hate this this
is why I would not be a good in
practical joker yeah I'd be so bad any
cuz I'm alright
coo-eee I wanna leave
they are unabashedly staring at ya my
instincts to throw you under the bus
completely I don't know why that's why
everyone to stand so no time billions
you're gonna shoot me in the leg when
the zombies are coming this isn't gonna
make any better
you busted the desk was it working I
mean like like a child of the court
[Laughter]
don't believe we here Bess out there
yeah we're straight everyone yeah you
know what you're right just go that way
yeah I think just go that way okay we're
in trouble
I knew it I knew her love dude that
guy's like hey hey that's the guy from
billions what's he doing out there
they're probably like forwards and
behind oh my god we're at all oh what a
lumbar we can't imagine at some point
it's painful or the grips has to hurt I
mean it's real tonsils go to open mouth
he's in a sweat suit did you guys get
you guys got it right yeah what's your
year you look celery it's called
personal questions elevator how many
people are you seeing currently yeah are
you an organ donor yeah are you
currently cheating Luke should be
President oh this is good we got a lot
of 10 against be special good
what is art is art like prisoner
questions is your clip Pierce okay say
now would you say your population
didn't get enough bonfire
well like subscribe follow all that
stuff at the bonfire SXM on Twitter
Instagram snapchat or wherever you do
computer stuff you know all the computer
places